the first key to monitoring gke cost
optimization
is ensuring that cluster administrators
have an understanding of how much of
their cluster resources
are actually used by workloads in the
cluster
with this data they can take steps to
ensure that fewer cluster resources
are idle or wasted let's take a look at
how we can utilize a monitoring system
around this
[Music]
as we explored in the previous video the
concept of bin packing is focused on
ensuring that most of our cluster
resources
are allocated to cluster workloads
cluster administrators want to achieve
efficient bin packing to ensure that a
cluster is not over provisioned
monitoring systems will be able to tell
cluster admins if this is the case
by letting them know how much of a
cluster's allocatable resources
are actually consumed by workload
requests
there are three main areas we want to
monitor to ensure that we are not
stranding resources across our cluster
cpu memory and the amount of pods we run
on each node cpu and memory are well
known concepts in kubernetes so let's
start with how we should monitor how
well
they're actually allocated in a cluster
up to this point we have discussed
monitoring at the aggregate cluster
level
with per cluster monitoring we are
getting a high level summary of how well
we are doing with cluster bin packing
however the larger the cluster and the
more diverse the machine types
the more important it becomes to monitor
at a more granular level
that will help cluster administrators
take action
monitoring at the more granular per node
pool level can help us take this action
this monitoring can help identify target
areas that cluster administrators
can improve cluster bin packing for
example if we are isolating a set of
workloads to their own node pool
that is not correctly sized to fit such
workloads
underutilization may not appear to be a
problem at the aggregate cluster level
but it could very well be a problem
within that node pool
for both cluster level and node pool
level monitoring we should collect these
four metrics around cpu and memory
allocatable resources which references
total cpu or memory available
from the cluster or node pool this value
will always be slightly lesser than the
total resources from the cluster vms
due to critical system components that
have to run on each node
requested resources which references
total cpu or memory requested by pods
running
in the cluster or node pool recommended
resources
which reference recommended cpu or
memory requests from the platform
which can come from components such as
vertical pod auto scaler
and finally used resources which
references
the actual cpu or memory utilization
from pods in the cluster or node pool
in this example dashboard for monitoring
cpu
we can see how these four metrics fall
together over a specified time window
this graph tells us for instance that
there is opportunity for cost
optimization
due to used cores falling well below the
requested core count
by workloads in the cluster however when
looking at this example dashboard for
monitoring memory you get a much better
picture of what is going on
workloads are requesting and using most
of the memory we have
available but barely utilizing the cpu
available
with this information we can consider
the types of machines we are running in
our cluster
or in our node pool can we provision vms
with the same amount of memory but with
less cpu
with the appropriate data at hand we can
now begin this exercise of answering
this question
to practice cost optimization the third
area we should monitor to ensure
efficient bin packing
is pods per node in gke
users can set the number of pods allowed
to run on a node
to a smaller than the default value
which is 110 pods
this is commonly used as a mechanism for
preserving ip addresses
since each pod in a cluster or in a node
pool gets its own ip
this feature in gke is called flexible
pod sider
if you set a small enough number of pods
on a node there's a chance that you
could schedule the maximum pods
per node without using a majority of the
allocatable cpu
and memory on that node this is also
possible
even with the default value of 110 pods
per node
should you have very large nodes with
smaller workload requests
thus it's important to monitor when you
brush up against the maximum pods on a
given node
especially if you are attempting to
achieve ip address preservation
monitoring across these key areas will
help cluster admins continually optimize
their cluster infrastructure
in a data-driven fashion this is
especially important as workloads scale
up and down
and when new tenants on board into the
cluster
be sure to check out the paper we
published on how to set up this
monitoring system
linked in the description below setting
this monitoring up
will lay the groundwork for the cluster
admins to work with cluster tenants
to ensure that they are doing the work
to perform app right sizing
we'll cover this in the next video so
stay tuned
you